françois poulet mathis journaliste
spécialiste des institutions européennes
bonsoir françois paul et mathis merci
d'être avec nous alors au sujet de
l'europe un emmanuel macron qui a plaidé
pour une unité de l'europe on va parler
avec vous notamment de ses annonces sur
les frontières parce que ça aussi il ya
eu un petit peu des allers-retours au
début le gros débat sur la fermeture des
frontières s'étaient ouhlala n'ont
jamais d'avis et puis l'a finalement on
se rend compte que l'europe prend des
précautions l'allemagne qui va contrôler
davantage les français déjà qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé de cette allocution
on va rester sur le plan européen avec
vous des manuels macron aujourd'hui qui
prône l'unité justement pense qu'il est
situé le problème le problème il est
européen alors on peut très bien
considérer qu'avec une telle crise d'une
telle ampleur et bien il faut que chaque
pays qui se débrouillent referme ses
frontières règle ses problèmes pays par
pays et ce exactement tout l' inverse
alors qu'on m'entende bien il s'agit pas
d'ouvrir toutes les frontières faire en
sorte que tout le monde puisse aller
dans tous les sens c'est pas ça on peut
très bien imaginer effectivement des
mesures de restriction de passage des
frontières
par contre la dimension des solutions
que l'on peut apporter à ce problème
c'est une dimension européenne pourquoi
parce que tout simplement on le voit
bien en italie qui est actuellement en
défaut d'appareils d'assistance
respiratoire
on le voit sur la recherche des
chercheurs qui cherchent à tous les par
tous les moyens d'aboutir à un vaccin le
plus rapidement possible mais on le voit
aussi dans la comparaison que l'on peut
faire dans les choix politiques des
différents pays
c'est peut-être instructive de savoir
comment les les opinions les décisions
qui ont été prises d'un pays à l'autre
ont-elles des effets point avait un
virus qui n'est qu'on ne connaît pas
bien dont on connaît pas bien les effets
il est très important de pouvoir
partager des expériences
donc c'est vraiment sur le plan européen
que des choses peuvent se passer mais on
dirait qu'on le découvre ce soir
françois pour les métis
emmanuel maintenant qu'il nous dit de
probable fermeture de frontières devront
être décidés à l'échelle européenne ça y
est enfin on se on se réveille pourquoi
on le fait maintenant est-ce qu'il
fallait pas le faire en aimant on
connaît très mal ce virus on connaît
très mal son mode de répartition son
mode de diffusion et donc quelle est la
bonne méthode personne n'a véritablement
la clé il y a deux méthodes qui sont en
concurrence actuellement le celle de
l'italie qui consiste à tous fermés et
celle de la france qui consiste à voir
un ciblage un ciblage précis pour faire
en sorte que les endroits où il ya des
foyers soit directement isolé maintenant
emmanuel macron vient d'annoncer sur le
plan de l'éducation nationale la
fermeture des écoles et des universités
c'est un papa qui va au delà
mais chacun peut avoir des expériences
différentes comme on ne sait pas encore
et effectivement pas d'unité sur neuf
puisque jusqu'à présent n'y avait que
neuf pays européens qui fermait les
écoles on est le dixième c'est pas c'est
pas grave c'est pas nécessaire vient le
moment où on ne connaît pas la méthode
idéale
on ne connaît pas on ne connaît pas dans
le moment on ne la connaît pas que des
pays prennent des choix politiques
différents ce qui est important c'est
que les responsables politiques
européens se concertent discutent entre
eux et ça et de voir comment ils
avancent comment cela progresse et puis
il y aura des décisions à prendre les
décisions à prendre
l'italie qui appellent au secours il
faut trouver des solutions à l'échelle
européenne pour ne serait ce que pour
ses histoires des six temps respiratoire
on puisse avoir des solutions
européennes qui évite des choix
absolument inadmissible que ceux tels
qu'on peut les inciter en italie donc
aujourd'hui la dimension européenne est
impérative alors l'unité de l'europe ne
pas céder au repli et nationalisme pas
non plus céder à l'individualisme les
décisions de montrer deux prises à
l'échelle européenne nous
emmanuel macron effectivement là aussi
pas de pression la décision il s'agit
pas forcément que la france accorde
pause sur un même schéma d'intervention
sur les frontières voilà voilà
bon il faut simplement qu'ils partagent
leurs expériences qui partagent leur
savoir et il faut que cela puisse
aboutir à des décisions qui sur le plan
européen sont importantes parce que
cette crise qui est absolument hors
norme va nécessiter des engagements
financiers considérables
déjà au niveau de certains des pays mais
les pays peuvent pas agir tout seul il
faut donc que l'europe
on a entendu tout à l'heure christine
lagarde il faut que l'europe autorise
certaine libéralisation par rapport à
des règles qu'elle s'était jusqu'à
maintenant octroyés et il faut
simplement savoir que ça m'a coûté cher
que des moments on veut éradiquer le
virus le plus rapidement possible bah il
faut agir avec des avec deux femmes est
allégué les gens semblent d'accord même
la l'inflexible normalement un gala
merkel voilà se montre beaucoup plus
flexible sur ce fameux 0% à 3% de
déficit
et quel que soit le plx écoutons qu'il
dit tout juste précise quand même que la
sphère des 3% est prévu dans les traités
il est prévu tout textuellement dans les
traités que en cas de crise grave et
nous y sommes en cas de crise grave la
règle de trois pour cent peut être
interprété et c'est bien ce qui va se
passer
alors l'europe avec l'italie qui est
remise un petit peu sur l'attitude des
français jusqu'à présent enfin voilà
tout au long de la journée c'était un
petit peu voilà en gros ne fanfaronnait
pas parce que ce qui nous arrive risque
fort de vous arriver
ce scénario françois pour les métis vous
semble probable un scénario à
l'italienne ou c'était un cas
spécifiquement il salue l'annoncé
possible et d'ailleurs je suis pas
compétent en la matière mais tous les
spécialistes tous les responsables
médicaux disent que ça peut très bien
arriver dans la stratégie française il
ya un élément qui est quand même
important qui est celle d'essayer
d'étaler dans le temps les cadets corde
les russes pour éviter d'avoir un
encombrement un embouteillage des cas
graves en particulier parce que c'est ça
le problème
le problème c'est pas la plupart des
gens qui seront soumis aux cordes à
virus et qui finalement s'en tireront
pas trop mal comme une véritable griffe
le problème c'est les cas graves c'est
ceux qui ont besoin d'assistance
respiratoire et c'est toute la
population qui est vulnérable et là il
ya partage d'expériences qui est très
important à communiquer en ce qui
concerne les personnes âgées
en ce qui concerne les malades sous
traitement des maladies chroniques
tout ça ça nécessite effectivement une
vision plus globale plus général et les
pays ne peuvent d'ailleurs il appelle à
l'aide
l'italie appelle à l'aide ce qui montre
bien que les pays seul ne peuvent plus
régler le problème
merci françois poulet mathis spécialiste
des institutions européennes